villé en fait la force
c'est en tout cas ce qu'ont bien compris
les états européens divisés affaibli
après la seconde guerre mondiale
alors oui 258 avec le traité de rome si
le pays de ses dix économies comment la
france l'allemagne et l'italie les
pays-bas la belgique et le luxembourg ap
il créé la sicile la communauté
économique européenne c'est la
naissance officielle de l'europe mais
aussi de l'assemblée parlementaire des
communautés composé de 140 de
députés sept ans fait l'ancêtre du
parlement européen
son siège est établi a strasbourg est
essentiellement pour des raisons
pratiques qu'est-ce que cette assemblée
utilisez locaux d'une institution déjà
existantes le conseil de l'europe alors
en 1962 cette assemblée prend le nom de
parlements l'européen son rôle est
d'abord consultatif il faudra attendre
les années 70 pour que le parlement
obtiennent un pouvoir pdg de terre
le parlement donc là
tony m
un rôle budgétaire qui n'est pas fait
encore énorme mais il a la possibilité
de contrôler certaines dépenses que
des recettes limite ils ne votent pas
l'impôt
elle il n'y a pas un impôt européen
mais il peut contrôler certaines
dépenses c'est en 1979 que le parlement
repères gagne enfin en légitimité
démocratique puisque les députés sont
élus au suffrage universel direct il
passe de 198 à 410
il faut noter que c'est pas la tête de
celle par le moko ps il ya souvent des
français
en 58 après des traités de rome le
premier thème présidente de
l'assemblée parlementaire européennes
etter
pères de l'europe comme on disait
c'était trop soumane
et puis mais elle comporte plus
important symboliquement
en 79
le premier président du parlement
européen élu au suffrage universel
celui de présidente
c'est simone veil encore une fois d'une
française
au fil du temps et avec sac nouveau
traité le parlement fait davantage
entendre sa voix face à la commission
et au conseil des ministres avec l'actif
unique en 1986 il obtient à nouveau
pouvoir c'est ce qu'on appelle la
coopération et avec elle le traité de
maastricht en 1992 là le parlement
passe à la vitesse supérieure
le traité de maastricht pas créer
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
qui est la codécision
c'est-à-dire que nous désarçonner le
parlement
pouvoir légiférer
ap égalité des droits abete le conseil
heyer actuellement c'est qu'aux
décisions et vraiment
presse que la voie législative
l'année 2009 marque les 30 ans du
parlement a voté un élu au suffrage
universel direct
depuis l'europe s'est considérablement
agrandi avec les 27 états membres
après les élections de juin 2009 736
députés siégeront à strasbourg ch
officielle du parlement européen